all right guys so today we're going to
talk about
um what was that uh
god what was that oh yeah short-term
memory loss
now this can relate to the beginnings of
dementia all the way over to
alzheimer's so the symptom of memory
loss has
everything to do with the hippocampus
and the greek term for hippocampus means
seahorse because that's the shape
and you have two of them one on the left
side one on the right side so that way
if one goes you have a backup so related
to short-term memory loss i have some
good news and some
bad news the bad news is that as you age
the hippocampus actually starts to
shrink
okay so age is definitely one thing
you're up against so you just have to
stay as young as
possible number two if you decrease
oxygen you can destroy the hippocampus
number three stress will definitely
affect the hippocampus
it'll actually make it atrophy and
shrink the more stress you go through
the more you can have atrophy or
shrinkage of your hippocampus
i mean it's pretty easy nowadays to
avoid stress right all right number four
high glucose
diabetics are at risk for having damage
to their hippocampus
so high carb diets are not very good for
the hippocampus at all
number five a vitamin b1 deficiency
so vitamin b1 is i would say the second
most important nutrient
for the hippocampus i put some links
down below for more information about b1
because
you want to make sure you're getting
enough b1 from the diet to make sure
that you can preserve
the hippocampus now number six
a vitamin d deficiency out of all the
areas of your brain
a vitamin d deficiency will affect the
hippocampus
the most so it's a very good thing that
vitamin d deficiency is very
rare nowadays or else we'd be in big
trouble
now that was a sarcasm because a vitamin
d deficiency
is extremely common among
most of the population on planet earth
and number seven
if you have a zinc deficiency that can
majorly affect the ability of your
hippocampus to function
resulting in short-term memory loss okay
so that's the bad news
what is the good news now the good news
is the hippocampus
is one of the only areas of the brain
that can completely regenerate
thank goodness for that so if we just go
ahead and look at the list
we have to stay as young as possible
number one we want to
increase oxygen to our hippocampus
exercise is one of the best ways to do
it another way would be to use the
hyperbaric oxygen therapy
but overall you want to keep your oxygen
at a very high level
now the next thing would be fasting
fasting
including intermittent fasting is a very
powerful therapy to increase something
called
bdnf brain derived neurotrophic
factor and so by doing fasting you
increase that compound
which directly increases neurogenesis
which is the
creation of new nerve tissue
all right next one is to start taking
vitamin d
as i said before vitamin d is the most
important
nutrient for your hippocampus and also
start consuming food
high in zinc that would be all the
shellfish
also beef liver has a good amount of
zinc in it
and taking more b1 is very very vital
i would recommend taking nutritional
yeast on a regular
basis and the last thing i want to
mention is to decrease your stress
as much as possible do whatever you can
to do that
and of course applying these other
things is also going to reduce stress
especially if you do regular consistent
exercise the type of exercise that will
increase more oxygen
long walks would be a really good thing
now the next thing is increasing your
ketones
ketones are the preferred fuel of the
brain
especially the hippocampus in fact
you're not going to be able to
regenerate the hippocampus
without feeding it ketones and there's
several ways of increasing ketones
number one getting in a low-carb diet of
course you probably already know that if
you're new to my channel
i put some links down below of exactly
what diet you need to be on
number two consuming mct oil
very very important medium chain
triglyceride fats
will turn into ketones and your brain
will
actually absorb them in preference to
glucose
and you'll see huge benefits you can
also
take exogenous ketones they're called
ketone
salts and that will also increase your
ketones they're a bit
expensive so it might be cheaper to take
the mct oil
but more important than mct oil in
exogenous ketones
is getting on a ketogenic diet keeping
your carbs low
and that's going to be very very
important in restoring the hippocampus
all right guys there you have it those
are the key things to help you
with short-term memory
before you go if you have a question
about a product or you're new to keto
and you want to know how to begin keto
or you're on keto
and you need a debug because it's not
going as smooth
i have a keto consultant standing by to
help you
this is just for the people in the us
hopefully in the future we'll be able to
answer everyone's call
but i put the number down below so you
can call
and get some help